so as you can see what am I going to eat
first up there's this summer fruits
right alpha plus beta plus gamma and
taking the negative over the other side
- okay now you're starting to see why
southern product of roots is not quite a
good enough way to describe when you're
going for polynomials okay because this
is the summer fruits and looking on the
end there you've got the product of
roots which is minus D on a but um
what's this guy what do you call him
he's got the song yeah what we say the
way we caught we we describe this which
is if you want to say this generally
speaking okay because you should be it
should look suspicious to you feel like
this is exactly the same thing that we
got with the quadratic right - be on a
right these these first two coefficients
here they're always going to be equal to
the sum of the roots but more
specifically you say you're taking them
one at a time right pants alpha plus
beta plus gamma plus Delta plus however
far you want to go right when you can
move up one C on a and please please
please watch out for the negatives okay
everyone always screws that up because
it's easy to forget that it's there or
it's not there Sione is still just some
of the roots
sort of it's the summer through it's two
at a time okay so in this case it's
alpha beta plus beta gamma plus alpha
gamma but for instance if we had a
quartic power of four not power of three
right there would be many more
combinations right you'd get alpha beta
gamma sorry Alpha Delta then you get
begun gamma beta Delta you're gonna get
gamma
hah and wait is that it that's right so
you just got to be careful and
methodical in the way that you write the
bouncing you catch everyone but that a b
c or a if it was a quartic and - DNA is
the sum of the roots three at a time
okay yeah they're all different kinds
but you see for instance if we were
doing a quadratic right some of the
roots two at a time
well there are only two roots so it's
just alpha B episode we would call that
the product of the roots right and for
the cubic that sum of the roots three
two tired
well there's only one way to combine
them in three you've got to take all
that women take the product right so
that's why this would be the product of
the roots for a cubed okay so obviously
this pattern which is really kind of
neat and interesting and this is what
this guy proved it generalizes for all
polynomials so